[Music]
so
[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
i'm pissed morgan unsensed coming up on
tonight's program the real george
michael there's a new documentary on the
singer's life is released i speak
exclusively to the great love of his
life kenny goss
and he's the man who knows not just how
the world will end he thinks he knows
when it will end rockstar astrophysicist
neil degrasse tyson will be here live in
the studio
and as the rail strike cribbles britain
it's time to take on the government i'll
ask transport secretary grant shaps why
he's not sorting out this mess at the
negotiating table
[Music]
[Music]
good evening welcome to piers morgan
uncensored tonight a lot of good stuff
tonight uh but we've also got our first
appearance by one of the british
government cabinet ministers the
transport secretary grant shap so quite
timely because at the moment i'm
trending number two in the uk on twitter
uh because of my interview a few days
ago with mick lynch who's the rmt union
boss who's brought britain to a
standstill with these rail strikes and
the reason the reason it's trendy is
because uh people have well they've been
outraged as of course they would on the
hard left they've been outraged
uh by me quizzing mr lynch about what he
put on his facebook profile picture now
let's just remind you if you didn't see
it on the exchange i have with him
let me show you what i believe is your
facebook page i want you to confirm or
deny it this is your facebook page
it's a picture
of the hood from thunderbirds can you
see the likeness
well i'm just wondering where the
comparison goes because he was obviously
an evil criminal terrorist mastermind uh
described as the world's most dangerous
man who really
is that
is that the level you're pitching this
at pierce i didn't put that picture on
your profile page yeah but you've chosen
to spend two or three minutes of this
interview you're talking about any
relevance because you seem so irritated
because you seem so irritated by the
comparison i'm not irritated at all i'm
completely you seem very irritated
well i'm not
you're not
this is your non-irritated face is it
what point are you trying to prove piers
i mean i'm not trying to try to win
you put it on your facebook page i'm
simply asking it's an odd choice for a
union boss who's about to go on a series
of structures
well on my facebook page i don't use it
much but on the facebook page the
profile pictures me and the dalai lama a
man of peace
there's a difference mr lynch between
that and the hood
a man of vengeful terrorist criminal
activity that breaks the planet
but let's be fair you do look like him
anyway that clip has gone viral uh it's
not had 1.5 million
views on the twitter clip alone it's had
another million on tick tock our first
million tick tock view it said millions
more on youtube instagram facebook so
thank you to the hood for not getting
irritated it's very clear from that
exchange that he wasn't irritated by
that so i'm hope that we haven't
irritated him further but in fact now
the entire country is watching it and
sharing his lack of irritation and to
all those who are outraged let me remind
you when i launched this show
the whole premise was to annoy all the
right people and today i feel my work is
nearly done
because i've annoyed all the right
people
well with more strikes planned for
tomorrow and saturday and the threat of
the further six months of mayhem is it
time the government got involved to sort
this mess out earlier i spoke to
transport secretary grant champs i began
by asking him how he's feeling amid all
this chaos
it's a bit it's a busy time and you know
as commuters try to get themselves into
work
the world has changed of course which
the unions don't seem to have realized
and many people uh simply working from
home where they can those who aren't are
the people that the unions claim they
want to represent but it's people who
need to get to work because their jobs
require them to be physically there
maybe hospital cleaners for example who
the rmt says they want to help they're
actually harming those people the most
and that's the great pity of what's
going on let me just cut to the quick
about what's going on here a lot of
people feel that notwithstanding the
fact that technically you're correct
network rail is their job they're the
employer they should be negotiating with
the unions the country is in total chaos
there's no sign of this ending and when
it comes to direct government
intervention in our rail system i mean
you couldn't have done more than you've
done in the last two three years you
missed pandemic by piling 16 billion
pounds worth of investment of our money
into propping it up and saving jobs and
so on which is to your credit but that
shows you are prepared to directly
intervene in keeping our trains running
during a pandemic which prompts the
question well why aren't you getting
involved now it doesn't seem to me to be
credible to have done all this
for so long and now to say actually not
my job gov
yeah look i mean this is a negotiation
over uh terms and conditions and pay
which is between the union and the
employer it is the only place that that
discussion can take place and uh it's a
stunt that uh the rmt mitt lynch are now
saying oh no what we need are ministers
in the room that's a stunt because
actually only last month
mick lynch was saying we would never
negotiate with the government actually
he said i would never go to negotiate
with the tory government which might
give something about his frame of mind
about all this there isn't actually
anything helpful that i could do by
being in the room in fact it would
undermine those negotiations because
they're not just about pay they're about
a whole host of other things what the
unions need to do is get back in the
room stop flouncing out and get on with
the talks how do you square though this
kind of new parsimonious view
of
tapping effectively what you can pay
people in the public sector with this
revelation today that the government is
looking to scrap the cap on banker
bonuses
and that's not being denied by the prime
minister today at pmq so is that true
have you told businesses that they
because we're now not in the european
union they no longer have to abide by
that rule that they couldn't have more
than 100 percent bonus well start the
government looks after the areas of of
uh the public sector which are under its
overall controls you know teachers
nurses doctors
railways those are the things that we
can directly affect what the private
sector pays under different
circumstances is their business i hope
you'll forgive me i'm not an expert on
on city
rules but my understanding is that there
are always uh discussions and
considerations about particularly now
we're outside of the eu uh where caps uh
lie in all of this but i will have to
leave it to the treasury and others who
will be better informed but they would
understand
they're not of course public workers
right but if you yeah i know i
understand the signature obviously but
clearly if the uk government is telling
people
in the banking world you can remove the
cap on your bonuses we're not in the
european union anymore haven't got to
abide by these caps off you go lads fill
your boots that does jar
very heavily with people right now who
are struggling to feed their kids or
queueing in food banks or indeed you
know people like mick lynch and half of
his members would say well this is
completely outrageous so i think it's a
perfectly valid question to ask any
member of the cabinet frankly
this is true have you guys given the nod
to the banking world you can give
yourself what you like as bonuses that's
a private sector activity uh what i'm
dealing with here with the with the rail
situation uh is the public sector i do
just want to say and i just i'll make
this point actually because it is
relevant um
don't run away with the idea that our
railway workers 100 000 of them are
poorly paid the medium salary the
average salary is 44 000 rail uh drivers
this is not the drivers on strikers
should point out but rail drivers median
average salary 59 000 a fifth of the mo
earn over 70 000. there are railway
drivers on over a hundred thousand
pounds this is not a badly paid sector
nurses for example would earn perhaps
thirty one thousand care workers i don't
i don't the government
last week i'm not i'm not in total
disagreement with what you're saying i
think if you're going to start shelling
out big pay rises nursing staff should
be top of the list it would be my view
but i do think that this this issue of
the private sector and a word from the
government that you can all fill your
boots with bonuses it could not be worth
time for you when you're trying to have
a position as a government that you
there's not enough money in the pot for
the public sector if the same government
is going around removing any caps so the
people in the banking community can
enrich themselves yeah i think that's a
very unfortunate juxtaposition and i
would simply ask you you clearly your
position seems to be you don't know the
truth about this but if you if that was
the case
would you share my view that it would be
outrageous well well actually i was
going to say there's a fairly
straightforward principle the government
deals with the money that it taxes and
raises and then spends on things like
salaries the government doesn't
generally get involved in legislation
about what for example a tv presenter
could earn or could earn as a bonus
that's that's unusual now after the
financial crash uh governments around
the world have been more involved uh in
uh in in in setting these private sector
or limits on private sector bonuses for
example um it's not generally where what
governments get involved with okay let
me just finally on these strikes mick
lynch says he's met every transport
minister tory transport minister in the
last year that presumably includes you
well he usually works with the railway
uh minister so they're a real real have
you many people no i don't i haven't met
with him no you've never met mick lynch
uh not knowingly no
not knowing me we think he's trapped
around your house when you're not
looking as far as i'm aware i didn't
want to mislead you that he was at an
event i was at once or something like
that but but no usually engaged
you know i understand all your reasons
and rationale for not getting involved
as you say in negotiation but given what
is going on in the country it's the very
last thing anybody in this country needs
or wants right now surely there's gonna
be a moment but it just makes sense for
you to pick the phone up to make lynch
and just have a conversation
ultimately you are the transport
secretary that is right but there is a
rail minister whose job it is
specifically but you're his boss right
with with rail well
let me ask the question if there's a
paid dispute on your tv channel uh which
i believe is ultimately owned by rupert
murdoch would you expect rupert murdoch
to walk in and resolve that dispute i'm
sure he didn't really
this way if the entire country had been
brought to its knees by whatever was
going on absolutely mick lynch has a
facebook profile picture of himself as
the hood the evil criminal mastermind
from thunderbirds and i did suggest to
him when we discussed this in a rather
animated way on this show last week that
you were the kind of virgil character
from the thunderbirds we actually look a
bit like virgil and i pointed out that
in the end virgil does emerge triumphant
well i mean i i think we can take these
comparisons um too far but
i i simply think you can't hold the
world back against things which have
fundamentally changed for example uh it
used to be the case if you weren't
wanted to go on the train you have to go
to a ticket office and pick up your
ticket now only one in eight tickets are
bought in that way and yet we have
exactly the same number of ticket
offices
almost exactly the same as we had in the
90s before the internet got going uh you
had a situation where the only way to
check a track to maintain it properly
was to send people out and have them
walk along the track it's dangerous i
read accident reports often frequently
from people who've died because they've
been hit by trains as they try and
maintain the track and nowadays a train
can be fitted with sensors and cameras
and takes 70 000 pictures per minute to
check that track much more safely and
more accurately than the human eye but
because the unions refuse to reform
themselves we end up with a railway
stuck in the 1950s and 60s that has to
change and he won't be able to hold out
again okay change because uh but because
he just insists on calling his union
members out on strike and we the country
can't live with that we ask you quickly
about romania we've got prince charles
you've got boris johnson going out there
um prince charles you know it was
briefed and not been denied believes
that the government's rwanda policy of
sending people who try and come in
illegally to this country to rwanda is
appalling what is your response to that
i think what is incredibly inhumane is
standing by and watching people drowning
in our channel watching people pay
people smugglers and criminals criminal
gangs to bring them to this country and
other than ringing our hands and saying
this is terrible
simply not having a plan to deal with it
and that is essentially well as far as i
can tell the position of everyone else
every other party every political party
in this country apart from the
conservatives party you may not agree
with the plan but we have a plan and
that is to ensure that people are put
off that we stop the uh the trade the
illegal trafficking people i've got a
big problem with with the taxpayer
shelling out five hundred thousand
pounds of pop for empty planes on time
well
which is not going to spain well in
which case let's in which case let's
tackle the law uh which uh sorry not the
law the the legal establishment which
will fight this endlessly and by the way
to put that into comparison we spend a
billion pounds a year on dealing with
the upshot of uh this uh uh
a a asylum uh system not working so uh
yeah i understand that it will cost
money to establish a new route but what
about all the money it costs to maintain
a a system which is fundamentally
brilliant
i agree if you keep being blocked though
by the law and the law is what it is
it's a law so they're they're currently
that's i mean you know the job i do in
this place behind me here is is is
change the law right the law isn't
working i understand but my point is to
change it my point is if you literally
can't get this plan to work at what
point do you abandon it and stop wasting
taxpayer money all right look i think
we're only at the beginning we're going
to make the plan uh work i mean we are a
determined government who do a lot of
difficult things we are prepared to take
those decisions how would you feel how
would you feel though how would you feel
if i said to you
all right mr shatson sorry we're going
to take your ukrainian family and we're
going to put them on a plane to rwanda
tomorrow so
the ukrainian family ukrainian family
that you're currently hosting yeah the
ukrainian family came that lives with me
could you have that conversation through
well i was gonna say they came here
through a legal understanding
i'm talking about this i'm talking about
the moral the morality of it really is
it could you imagine having that
conversation with them and saying
actually actually you're not going to
stay in safe britain you you're going to
go to rwanda which has a pretty poor
record
that's no more relevant than saying can
i imagine my family being asked to go to
randa i mean this is we're talking about
here people who've been trafficked by
criminal gangs
across the channel
illegally
knowing that what they're doing uh will
it is illegal and knowing that when they
get here in the future uh there's a good
chance that you will end up being in
rwanda and what will happen in the end
of course once that policy is up and
running is that it will close down the
criminal gangs let me ask you about what
it's been like to have a ukraine family
living in europe um we're we're you know
delighted to have them uh with us the
the the they're lovely people the
country's under attack and the way i
feel about what's going on in ukraine is
it's not just um putin attacking some
country you know across across in
eastern europe he's attacking all of our
freedoms and all of our rights and if we
don't stop him there he'll carry on west
we've seen this sort of thing in the
world before so i think it's a small
price to pay to have a family live with
us
in return for you know trying to to help
with that situation well it's a great
thing that you do uh for that family and
i'm sure it's hugely appreciated by them
and by ukraine uh thank you very much mr
schatz to be my first cabinet minister
thanks
well answers next is one of the most
influential recording artists of all
time there's a new film on his life his
screens today are we any closer to
knowing the real george michael he's
former long time partner great love of
his life kenny goss joins me exclusively
after the break his first television
interview in five years
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to baseball and uncensored
well from the formation of wan to his
untimely death george michael was an
enigma as well as a gigantic talent but
one person who knew the real george was
his former longtime partner kenny goss
i'll speak to kenny in just a moment for
his first television interview in five
years but
first there's a new final work i guess
it is it's a documentary about george
michael's life it claims to give an
insight into his very public career and
his tumultuous private life let's take a
look at the clip
you have a right to walk away
the music industry takes away that right
from every artist it signs george had
raised the bar to a whole new level it
was a revolutionary thing and i want to
leave songs i believe i can leave songs
that will mean something to other
generations
george michael who was without a doubt
one of the most talented
singer-songwriters this country in fact
the world has ever seen
and his death was obviously tragically
early and uh we all miss george no one i
guess probably more than my next guest
who's kenny goss who spent 15 years
with george kenny it's great to talk to
you
hey how are you we don't really know
each other but i knew george quite well
and had some great times with him
seems like i know you from from
uh
weren't you in the showbiz editor or
something like that years ago when you
were when you were i'm a lot older than
you but you were it must have been 20
years maybe yeah would you you've aged
better seems like i know you uh yeah i
used to do i actually ran
around some of the papers but i used to
i used to see quite a lot of george you
ran the sun for a while in the news of
the world no yes and also the daily
mirror yeah yeah
yeah but i actually i'm not doing that
about my dealings with george was he was
always incredibly candid you know i can
remember some dinner parties where he
was just you know outrageously funny but
very revealing um i did some interviews
with him he was the same he was a kind
of heart on the sleeve kind of guy and
i'm just curious this documentary film
it has a lot of people talking about him
it doesn't have you and i always felt
that if everybody around george's life
you would have known him probably as
well as anyone
i would definitely say
uh
he would say that as well absolutely uh
what you're very correct about is george
uh was one of the most honest people
i've ever met and sometimes uh he almost
used honesty
uh as a weapon not and i mean weapon in
i'm gonna tell you this i need to tell
you this uh i've done something you need
to know and uh
uh so you always got the truth from him
absolutely i by the way the documentary
that you are talking about the one that
you and i did correct no i'm actually
talking about the new one which is
coming out now with all the big stars in
it uh you're talking about the simon
napier bell film right okay i don't know
a lot about that one right i do know
about it but uh i haven't really watched
it uh i think i know what it says
uh
uh but but uh i wish you luck
i mean i think the the point that people
have made about it is it's a it's a bit
of a
not a whitewash of his life but it may
not be as
real as it should be and that the
reality of george's life was that
towards the end of his life certainly
the last decade or so he was on a pretty
downward spiral into
you know a very difficult
kind of lifestyle uh he was pretty
honest about it to me
that even when he was with you and
you've been very candid about this as
well you know it was a kind of open
relationship and of course from his from
his point of view he had lots of oh i
think from he was probably and i'm not
saying anything i would say he uh
probably was more open than me
uh but
i loved him very much he knew that
the public perception of george is what
it is i'm having trouble hearing him but
you guys can you know oh can you hear me
can you appear
this
that well this airbrush thing keeps
calling out i apologize uh all right
i'm
is it live tv don't worry about it i
just wanted to ask you uh can you hear
me
you can hear me okay
i can hear you now yes yeah i just
wanted to ask you what do you think the
biggest misconception about george was
that the public may have had
um
i think the thing that
i always try to remind myself of and
this really wasn't a misconception i
think most people knew this was i don't
think he ever thought he had a good
looking moment in his life
uh
uh i always tried to remind him or tell
him you know you look really good today
uh you're a handsome man uh
it was very difficult for him uh
and uh
and it seems so i think to many people i
know that's well known but i think to
many people
they would think he would have a much
higher
sense of hey i'm a good-looking guy
and uh you know that i'm sure but uh
that's something i'll never forget one
of the first times that we've probably
been together two weeks
and he uh or maybe three he came home
and he said
uh darling what's good looking about me
and i said that's why are you asking me
that and he said he told me he said
someone said you were better looking
than me
and
i said uh
darling
what was the and i asked him the
question again because i really had
never had a guy ask me that question
and uh i said
there were so many things i should have
said but i said your lips
and uh now if it had been a girl or
anybody that had more time i'd have said
everything's good looking about you
don't you get it i'm i mean you know he
was you know
always voted most handsome in the world
all these different things and uh
but what he did know
uh was that he was a talented man and a
good songwriter i mean he was he was
without a doubt i mean he was one of the
greatest the greatest talents i think
musically this country in the world has
seen certainly in my lifetime
i think um
that's the thing that always amazed me
um
uh
i and probably the most unmusical person
that he could have ever gotten with uh
he always said i had the same five cds
in my cars when we met and uh
i can honestly tell you
um
i can't remember the words
to the songs you wrote about me and it's
uh it's a shame i've since he's been
passed away i've actually started
reading the lyrics
and uh actually i started doing that
before he passed away and he said oh my
god
he said i liked you better when you
weren't reading them because you know i
would ask him almost childlike questions
like like
i this room you say that i'm in
uh where is this room
and and this chair it's a darling it's
symbolism
and i and i said okay i said but uh
are we gonna see each other i said
you're an atheist
you know questions like that that were
very childlike but but it made me think
and i did understand what symbolism was
but i said i'm always an angel in all
the songs
and i said are you my angel
and i said you called me a drunken angel
darling
i said i said i said you know if you
know how angels work they don't go they
don't drunken angels don't get many
assignments
you know i mean kenny you hadn't you had
you had 15. you had 15 years with george
and it was a great love affair well that
was how you said that because uh it was
15 years yeah and um
uh and he said something once and it and
it was i said darling why did you say we
weren't together two and a half years
and and you know he had already started
kind you know not being necessarily as
president as
we'd gotten used to as he had been and
his answer was just simply
darling i don't know i just did it
and um
and i said okay uh how are you
uh yeah
and towards the end is it right to say
that i mean would you have been worried
about the state that george was in with
all the drugs i was worried about him
all the time yeah yes yes i mean but
please don't
say that the wrong way it's it's if you
love someone you're worried about him
you know it's
uh
that time when i said that you know
fluffs his drugs down the toilet that's
just because i was worried about it
uh
uh i'm so cautious now uh about
everything i say and it's
you know it's a tough way to live
uh
because
you know i mean i you know i was quite
pleased
for 14 years being long suffering
you know i didn't really like uh
because my if you google my name it
often says long-suffering partner kenny
goff a long-suffering texan and uh
and uh but you know
i really did try to be always be there
for him and he knew that you know um
um he
he i'm
i know he chose me to please his mother
i mean he told me that you know um
he had this
view that my mother his mother and i was
very much alike and in a lot of ways we
were i would say i'm probably
uh not probably i'm
much more uh
a guy that
plays by rules
uh and she was kind of the same way i
mean i'm also not judgmental at all
but uh
you know
uh
if you if a speed is a certain uh
you're supposed to drive at this speed i
drive at that speed if you're supposed
to you know and he really played by his
own rules kenny when you heard when you
heard that really
when you heard that he died at such a
horribly young age
obviously you would have been massively
shocked but what were your emotions
about it all given that you'd spit up
from him but you'd stay closer um
oh we'd stay uh close uh
um
but i you know
we'd all expected him to die
i had spent so much time uh
when we lived together uh
being worried about him
and
honestly uh you know he
hated the fact that i worried about him
so much uh
he
what's the line he says in the song he
says um
i could see it in your eye when you
looked at me that way it tears me in two
and uh
it really did uh
i just didn't know what to do
and kenny was uh
really close friend
when you look back on your relationship
all your time with george
what's your favorite memory
if i could relive a moment you have with
him uh
um
there's so many that uh
and what i what i always do notice is
that
that there was a lot longer time that i
was incredibly happy with him than i was
wearing with him
like i might watch an interview with you
and go wow he looks good then
or parkinson and and he was and he
always said such wonderfully kind things
about me
uh it's
and that you know that's makes me feel
good because you know
he always said
that i saved his life
uh i think that's you know a bit
uh much but uh
i really did try and and he often got
upset with me because
i don't think i ever called him and
didn't say
darling
please uh a lot of people love you
yeah
i don't think he ever knew just how much
he was loved he was an amazing character
i loved george i thought he was
fantastically enthusiastic brilliantly
talented people forgave him for
everything we did we did they did i mean
it was you know you know why kenny
literally he had a fantastically british
sense of humor and he got him out of
every scraper
it was the human got him out of every
screen he was that was
absolutely yeah
kenny i've got to leave it there
it's great funny beards i'm sorry we've
got a yeah yeah i've got a gig thank you
kenny it's great to talk to you uh i've
always wanted to have a chat with you i
love you it sure is uh uh i i wish i had
more time to talk to you i just want to
say he was one of the most wonderful man
in the world yeah uh
and uh i want people to remember that
i'm so glad that our true
honest documentary is out yeah it's such
a relief well i think be a lot of talk
about george and a lot of uh stuff about
both these films that have come out but
i appreciate you joining me tonight
kenny and uh you know it'll be good to
actually remember what a genius he was
everything else all the best
yeah thank you have a great day thank
you bye
george michael what a talent he was well
i'm sensitive next he's the man who
knows how the world will end but that's
not what keeps superstar astro
businesses neil degrasse tyson up at
night so what on earth does
i'll talk to him the rock star astra
visited himself live in my studio what
tree this was gonna be
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
well welcome back to peace balloon says
i am very excited now i don't get
excited by too many guests but i've
always wanted to sit down with this guy
because he's one of the well he's
probably the
number one astrophysicist in the world a
rock star of space if even as we've been
sitting here he's been telling me what's
on my own screen behind me because to me
it looks like just a big maze that he
knows and he is neil degrasse tyson
thank you because you happen to be in
the country i just happen to be in the
happening to lure you to my studio i'm
so happy about it this happened to be in
the hood
before we go any further what is this
thing behind we put here okay so this is
uh these stars that are coming through
that's just special effects but in the
background is an actual image of the
milky way galaxy really and coming up
right now is the galactic center behind
us and the center there is there's it
lurks a supermassive black hole dining
on any stars that wander too close look
you have a gigantically large brain for
this kind of stuff right you accept that
it's the same size as everybody else's
brain i just prioritize what i care
about differently from others
well i think what you're brilliant to do
you've got this terrific book which
comes in a moment but you're brilliantly
crystallizing the really important
questions in life one of which is how
long have we got here yeah well there
are some ideas about that because we
still don't know enough about the forces
that will end at all sorry uh we might
have a hundred years on earth
at the rate we're going
really no sorry there's earth issues
that require geopolitical solutions
self-harm okay correct and then there's
the universe the death of the sun the
collision of the milky way galaxy with
the andromeda galaxy and possibly the
big rip how would okay how would the sun
die oh sun like any star it will run out
of fuel in its core and it starts
changing it starts bloating and getting
so large that it will engulf the orbit
of mercury and venus and come very close
to earth so imagine looking on the
horizon and sunrise is half the sky
okay that would be terrifying is this
even starting to happen no not yet no we
have another several billion years if
you're going to prioritize with that's
right that's a dropped intro isn't it
what you're worried about yeah let that
one go all right but there's another one
the big rip that if the expansion of the
universe
accelerates
at a continued rate
and it goes unchecked
the universe will be expanding
in 22 billion years it'll expanding
faster than the fabric of space time can
keep up with it and it'll just rip
and i'm terrified by this for 22 billion
years
why are you terrified you're not going
to be here i'm telling you nobody you
know is going to be here
i just
it's okay to be scared of things that
can we stop happening the big red
we can't stop
climate change apparently are you
worried about the big rip we're going to
stop the big rip of the universe the big
rate would be it we're pretty
incompetent and on so many levels i i
would not hold that whole high hope what
about another threat to civilization
here i i had the last interview with
professor stephen hawking which was a
memorable experience about his his study
in cambridge university and i asked him
about the threat of from a.i artificial
intelligence this is what you said
is artificial intelligence
going to be the end of us
and if it's not
how do we best work with it there is a
greater danger from artificial
intelligence if we allow it to become
self-designing
for then it can improve itself rapidly
and we may lose control
now i'm really more and more about
the potential for ai to self-design is
it going to happen do you think there's
no reason to think that that won't
happen the question is what minute will
that occur
because the moment it becomes self
self-aware
and it can learn on its own well
exponentially what did he mean professor
hawking by by self design well just
consider how long do you go to school to
learn how to read write and do
arithmetic or lately it just looks like
people
just
read or write but no arithmetic
how long is that you're in school for
years and years and years
a computer
that is self-aware
and has access to all the knowledge of
the internet it can build on whatever
foundation it had in the previous moment
to to accelerate that learning so it can
acquire all knowledge and all wisdom in
a matter of minutes are we empowering
this should we stop should we hit the
buffers on this there are people experts
who definitely feel that way i'm not as
apocalyptic about it i think ai is not
we're not going to build the one machine
that controls everything but right now
if you had told someone 20 years ago i
drive a car that can steer itself and
tell me where grandma's house is to
avoid traffic in real time they would
say that's ai
okay in the days of the jetsons they
imagined robots as humanoid objects
walking around doing tasks they weren't
thinking that the car was the robot that
the telescope was the robot that your
coffee machine is the robot they weren't
thinking that they had a robot operate
the coffee machine right the robot drove
your car so we if we infuse ai in all
the areas of our lives that serve our
needs then i don't see ai becoming
centralized in a way that then takes
over some people think that elon musk is
ai
you know elo i'm not offering you when
yeah yeah i knew him when
he had a great line he says you know how
to make a small fortune in space start
with a big
that was a good line but now he made a
big fortune he's doing lots of very
interesting things in space uh but one
of the issues up there is the space is
getting quite cluttered with stuff
including elon's i mean what's the
answer to this yeah it's not clear and
just today one of the reasons why i'm in
london is to attend a space
sustainability summit look at those two
words together space sustainability uh
we see these
trails of satellites going across the
sky they call them constellations of
satellites and that pisses me off
because the constellation of stars that
don't move across the sky they took our
word and caught naming their their their
satellites after this so so there's
thousands of satellites in the sky
creating these streaks how dangerous is
that
well
first it's ugly to those who want to
just bask in the majesty of the night
sky plus it makes
further space commerce hard because
space gets crowded then and some some
satellites have been
actively destroyed china did it first we
did it second russia did it third and
okay i didn't destroy your satellite i
destroyed one of my own but you saw it
okay
have you been to space i no no would you
like to i okay so you know the folks
like uh like um
yeah all these guys so william shatner
william shatner so if this is school
room globe you know how high up
they went
the thickness of two dimes they're
nothing really no one and i'm an
astrophysicist you're gonna say that's
bad i'm not where do you want to go go
to moon mars beyond give me a
destination that's not boldly going
where hundreds have gone before
professor hawking told me if he knew he
had his last day on earth it was all
about to end ai or otherwise he said he
would he would want to be with his
family playing wagner and drinking
champagne what would you do wow
okay literally i said to you right now
all right you're right the world is
about to end and it's happening in six
hours what are you gonna do i would say
what can i do
with my intellect and those of others to
prevent the world from ending in six
hours but assuming you couldn't do it no
no i don't i don't assume that no excuse
me okay you have these photos of people
escaping cities that are about to be
leveled by a hurricane what are you
gonna do no one is saying why don't we
tap the cyclonic energy of the hurricane
use that energy to drive the the power
needs of the city and then the hurricane
goes away you know who thinks that way
stem professionals science technology
engineering and math professor hawking
he had this obsession about working out
what the black hole was right what is
your obsession what's your weird thing
you would love to crack it's never been
solved i i want to know our equations
tell us that if you go into a black hole
the time works out so that the future
history of the universe you just came
from plays out to infinity and another
space time opens up in front of you so i
want a mapping of all the new space
times that the black holes are providing
so you're all basically obsessed with
the same thing black holes well who
wouldn't be i find them a little bit
black
black holes the way kids are obsessed
with t-rex yeah every kid knows a t-rex
right yeah i think it's because it's a
threat that it can eat you that that
that has earned its respect neil it's a
this book welcome universe absolutely
fantastically fascinating thank you
you are a remarkably fascinating this is
like the original textbook that spawned
a series of books this latest one is the
the universe in 3d right there are
glasses that are part of it and the
objects in the universe pop
and they're they they transform from
just a picture of a planet to
a world as a planet we even show the
constellation and you realize
constellation is spread in three
dimensions it's not just
sadly we run out of time it is and what
a pleasure please come back again next
time you're here we'd love to have you
back great great to finally talk to you
probably well it says it next the prince
of wales has arrived in rwanda but got
his work cut out to save the
commonwealth will he crumble under king
charles tonight's peers back esther
krakow and julie bindle will debate that
a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back prince charles we'll set up
this stall to save the commonwealth
during a trip to rwanda insisting that
members are better and stronger together
got his work cut out though with many
countries poised to potentially become
full republics when the prince becomes
king having maintained their links to
the royal family in some cases out of
respect to the queen
australia and jamaica are among those
countries earmarked to potentially one
day want to cut their ties so will the
commonwealth crumble when charles does
become the monarch i'm joined by
tonight's peers back talk tv contributor
esther cracker and author julie bentley
welcome to both of you thank you so
julie i know you're a massive fan of the
royals
but you're not you don't really believe
in it right you don't you don't think we
should have a monarchy and so
de facto the commonwealth falls does it
i'm a republican um i respect that the
queen works extremely hard and she
didn't really have much choice in her
role so i'm not rabid but no i think
that the commonwealth should die when
she dies and i think that for many
countries and countries i've visited
kenya uganda and others for them it's
only really the elite that think that
the commonwealth is worthy of any
attention and whereas other people
especially those that live in poverty
and hardship they think that ties with
nato and the un are probably far better
far better serve them than the
commonwealth
i mean i've been in australia recently
where they've had you know there's a bit
of republicanism in the air but i
definitely got the feeling they're quite
a way away from wanting to sever their
link but a lot of it is pegged to the
queen tremendous respect for this unique
world figure really no one's quite sure
what's going to happen when she is sadly
no longer with us we're not sure when
that will be obviously but there is a
lot of sort of precariousness around the
monarchy and the commonwealth all of it
what do you think i think it's quite a
pity that you know the commonwealth has
now just become synonymous with the
queen as opposed to the royal family um
and you know i actually dispute the idea
that it's just you know amongst the
countries that you were mentioning it's
just an elitist idea actually if you
think about the commonwealth and the
potential of the commonwealth it gives a
lot of these countries a lot of
visibility so if you imagine you're a
small african country in the middle of
nowhere you know petitioning the u.n to
help solve a political dispute or
anything like that doesn't really get
the attention of these large
organizations but you can have direct
access to countries like india canada
the uk and they are actually far more
useful in solving these sort of issues
than you know big organizations i agree
with you
small countries that normally would not
get the attention of the un but even
brexit i mean obviously we haven't seen
the realization of that yet but there's
so much potential with this organization
post-brexit to actually deepen its ties
with the commonwealth i think one of the
issues i have with people that took down
on the commonwealth is really
understanding britain's place
post-brexit and in the 21st century as
it is now it's not the you know britain
that came out of the second world war
the british empire all that everything's
evolved and the royal family will evolve
with that but we also have to understand
the commonwealth's role in that there's
so many opportunities to to expand
britain's you know touch around the
world and the values that britain had um
um
hold so dear but i think it's so sad i
did feel with the platinum jubilee it
was a uniquely british occasion and when
you travel the world like i've done a
lot you know there's a lot of people
envious of what we have here this royal
family this pomp and pageantry you know
people say what's the point of it i said
well actually that's the point of it
it's something uniquely british it pays
for itself through tourism most of the
time
that's true well it's pretty true i
think it pays some businesses through
tourism i don't think it goes directly
to the people whereas from the people
attacks goes directly to the royal
family didn't you feel a little twinge
of patriotic
further
i saw all the flags waving and i don't
know an issue i don't have an issue with
patriotism i think that you know we
should be proud of the things that we're
good at doing and that we should be
proud of the things that we that we
should be proud of but i don't think we
have to see that through the lens of a
privileged family that is
it's obscene when you think about the
homelessness and people using food banks
and you see the vast wealth and
privilege of a family that we're
supposed to do
but there's much more than that they do
they do an awful lot of work for
charities up and down the country they
do a huge number of public engagements
things which were bore me rigid they're
doing them every day all day exactly
the royal family is a lot more than just
a privileged family i completely agree
with yes they are a privileged family
but there are a lot more than that and i
think a lot more is at stake than just
saying let's get rid of this privileged
family let's get rid of the you know the
commonwealth and all of these things i
feel like
you know it's not just um countries that
were in the british empire that part of
you know the commonwealth there's rwanda
obviously moses um i think it's gonna be
yeah of course
i've gotta jump in here very quick test
apparently there's a flamingo test where
if you can balance on your leg for ten
seconds or more you've got a longer life
ahead of you i'm going to spare you
because you've already said
you don't want to do it absolutely get
up here okay let's do this right up we
go on one foot we've got 20 seconds how
many heels i'm gonna go have to go
okay
one two three
four
five six
seven
eight
nine i said you were wobbling i am rock
solid i'm gonna live forever you after
kraku i've got problems and you julie
very sensible
much what are you up to keeping us
sensitive and good night
[Music]
it's no holds barred on my show piers
morgan uncensored idiotic insensitive
the hypocritical the blows you must not
do that the punch-ups are you
interviewing me or am i interviewing you
the fights there'll always be somebody
else to fight i didn't
and the knockouts it was a free and fair
election and that you lost turn the
camera off come on find me on talk tv
you know you want to well of course it's
unsensitive
[Music]
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm zora solomon health
officials have declared a national
incident after traces of polio were
found in the sewage works in east london
while the risk to the public is low
brits are being urged to check their
vaccination status as the virus was
eradicated in the uk in 2003
the transport secretary has denied
claims he wrecked negotiations between
unions and rail leaders meaning
tomorrow's strikes will go ahead the rmt
union accused grant shaps of refusing to
withdraw threats of redundancy for
workers but shats call this a total lie
and foreign secretary liz trust says the
uk is ready to support afghanistan after
over a thousand people were killed as a
6.1 magnitude earthquake struck the
country
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you